bonjour je suis né à paris
j'habite
j'ai grandi à côté de paris
alors je prends les transports en commun
c'est un joueur j'adore les transports
en commun parce que c'est la scène de
notre société de notre vivre ensemble il
ya quelque temps je changer de quai
entre les rer b et leurs airs à et dans
mon champ de vision
j'aperçois un jeune homme qui sort de
son sac un stylo
et qui dessine aux yeux à la barbe des
300 voyageurs qui était sur le quai un
tag au bas mot sur le quai une dizaine
d'agents de sécurité avec des gilets
fluo
là aussi au nez à la barbe de ses dix
agents de sécurité notre inconnu
griffonné le mur quelque chose qui m'a
pris dans le ventre et qui m'a laissé
penser que ce que je voyais c'était
témoignage d'une de ces incivilités
quotidiennes qui abîme notre vivre
ensemble qui sont l'expression la à un
instant donné d'une colère d'une peur de
quelque chose qui a fait passer ce jeune
homme à l'action juste position passive
il est passé à l'action aux yeux et à la
barbe de tous les passagers pour
signifier sa colère sa rage j'ai réalisé
que ces incivilités quotidiennes
ensemble elles formaient une voix une
force qui est un véritable défi
quotidien et d'agression pour notre
vivre ensemble
j'y reviendrai mais je ne les condamnent
pas ces sensibilités je les constate
je suis absolument convaincu que c'est
la somme de ces petites actions qui
ensemble pèse et influence sur notre
qualité de vivre ensemble de sociétés
ces incivilités
je vais pas vous les énumérer
aujourd'hui et vous les rencontrez comme
moi c'est une priorité grillé un passage
piéton avec des enfants qui s'apprête à
traverser
c'est un mégot jeté sur un trottoir
c'est des petites actions
il y a plusieurs milliers d'années les
égyptiens arrachait de la roche des
obélisques monumentaux et jusqu'à ce
qu'on découvre le chantier d'un
obélisque inachevé on avait encore
beaucoup d'incertitudes sur la façon
dont cette roche pouvait être travaillés
par les ouvriers égyptiens et on a
appris grâce à ce chantier de belize
qu'inachevé que des marteaux d'à peu
près 5 kg gros comme deux fois un point
était battu inlassablement
inlassablement pendant des mois par des
milliers d'ouvriers pour former les
contours de l'obélisque pour l'arracher
à la roche et moi l'intuition que j'ai
c'est que ces sensibilités
ces petites actions qui définit notre
vivre ensemble au quotidien
elles ont malheureusement la capacité de
faire émerger les modèles et les
dirigeants dont on n'a pas envie
alors moi aujourd'hui je voudrais vous
offrir un sourire ce sourire mon sourire
en réaction parce que je pense qu'on
peut peser en agissant en réaction des
incivilités par des actes positifs
quotidien un sourire c'est simple un
sourire et pourtant
posez vous la question combien de fois
en donnez vous chaque jour j'en suis
tellement convaincu qu'avec cette
personne car emmanuel grange j'ai
cofondé il ya huit ans une entreprise
sociale et solidaire qui s'appelle
microdon micro dont les arrondis
solidaires des petits dons pour les
associations d'intérêt général qui ont
besoin de ressources qui ont besoin de
décupler leur capacité d'action
si à la caisse des magasins chaque jour
on abandonnait les quelques centimes qui
sépare nos achats de leurs suivants et
que ces milliers ces millions d' acte de
générosité faisait fâche faisait voix
faisait corps pour ensemble réseau n'est
plus fort que les incivilités du
quotidien aujourd'hui autour de moi chez
micro dont une vingtaine de gens
extraordinaires ont permis de développer
ces micro dons dans 15 20 enseignes de
distribution dans 200 entreprises et
c'est plus de 1 million et demi d'euros
qui ont été distribués en 2016 à plus de
300 associations
cette jeune femme est en train
d'accueillir les clients à l'entrée
d'une supérette pour leur proposer de
faire un don à son association et cette
jolie photo illustre à mon sens à
merveille cette métaphore puisqu'on voit
s'effacer à côté d'elle une incivilité
ce tag c'est ma conviction on peut faire
émerger des tonnes d'actions positives
du quotidien des choses positives
les actions quotidiennes elle se
présente à vous dans tous vos actes mais
elles sont encore trop méconnu faites
vos achats
et lorsque vous achetez du tac du cacao
du café des bananes acheter du commerce
équitable
la personne qui les a produites vivra
décemment de ses revenus grâce à ce
label recycler les bouteilles de péter
les bouteilles plastiques dans les
machines lemon tree
elles vous donneront des coupons de
réductions dans les magasins et seront
recyclés en petits copeaux qui serviront
à leur tour à fabriquer de nouveaux
matériaux lorsque vous achetez un café
acheter un café suspendu vous payez deux
cafés le second que vous ne m'aurez pas
sera à disposition d'une personne qui
dort dans la rue à froid ou a besoin
d'un petit peu de chaleur
faites vos recherches sur internet en
utilisant l'îlot un moteur de recherche
solidaire chaque centime générés par les
revenus publicitaires de vos recherches
sera redistribué sous forme de gouttes à
des projets d'associations
enfin lorsque vous payez vos achats en
ligne et que le site propose avec pays
green une solution de dons et d'arrondi
au profit d'associations passer à
l'action fait corps améliorons notre
vivant sans notre vivre ensemble
des petites actions positives cette
splendide photo qui est celle de mon ami
et laurent de martini elle met en scène
un coiffeur américain qui a décidé de
sillonner le monde est d'aller à la
rencontre des plus défavorisés pour leur
offrir un quart d'heure de son temps
leur redonner dignité espoirs en les
mettant devant une image de leur visage
rafraîchi qui leur redonne confiance
c'est un de ces actes qui renforcent
cette capacité qu'on a à mieux vivre
ensemble au quotidien
est ce que j'aurai avec je veux partager
au travers de vous avec cette photo
c'est que de cette somme d'actes
positifs généreux émergent nos
dirigeants nos modèles nos personnalités
de demain ce qu'on a envie de voir
illustré incarner la beauté de notre
capacité à vivre ensemble
aujourd'hui je suis entrepreneur social
oeuvre pour que des associations capte
des nouvelles ressources au travers de
vos générosité quotidienne mais demain
je rêve encore plus grand je rêve que
ces micro don puisse impacter
significativement notre société notre
vivre ensemble et qu'on puisse demain
mesurer l'amélioration de tout ça au
travers d'un indicateur nouveau un
indicateur qui n'est pas un indicateur
économique comme le produit intérieur
brut ou le pnb mais un indicateur qui
reflète notre bonheur le bnb
lebron le bonheur national brut bien sûr
cette équation du vivre ensemble
elle est extrêmement compliqué et je ne
sais pas la résoudre aujourd'hui j'ai
seulement une infime partie de la
réponse au travers de ses civilités du
quotidien mais ce dont je suis certain
c'est que ces incivilités
elles ne peuvent pas être condamnés
elles font partie de notre société
elles sont là elles nous touchent
quotidiennement et vos messages pour
finir ce sera crayon plus fort avec les
civilités du quotidien et les sons moins
de place aux incivilités tous les jours
merci
[Applaudissements]